I think you were aware that I was up in
New Hampshire last week to conduct a
focus group with some Republicans and
independents or either strong supporters
viewers or leaning toward you one of the
things that a lot of those people said
was he's a billionaire he's successful
we love that about it but he's also one
of us one of us are were the phrase that
came up a lot how do you explain that
people who see you is so different from
them could also see you as being one of
them well I'll tell you it's very
interesting and I did happen to watch
that it was such a nice great group of
people but you know they see the country
like I do it's run by incompetent people
we're being ripped off left and right by
China by everybody I mean I don't it's
not just China it's everybody I mean we
don't make good deals anymore they want
to see it stopped from a political
standpoint we'll have better
relationships with those countries than
we do now now it's a one-way street out
and they all hate us it'll change very
dramatic mr. Trump also up in New
Hampshire in a new poll voters there
Republican voters are rating you as the
best to deal with the economy amongst
the Republican field obviously people
know you're a successful businessman but
we want to talk a little bit about your
views on things relate the economy so I
want to start with the ex-im bank that's
a big debate within the Republican Party
now about whether it should still exist
what is your views of the pros and cons
on the ex-im bank and where do you come
down on it in the end I don't like it
because I don't think it's necessary
it's a one-way street also it's a sort
of a feather betting for politicians and
others and a few companies and these are
companies that can do very well without
it so I don't like it I think it's a lot
of excess baggage
I think it's unnecessary and when you
think about free enterprise it's really
not free enterprise I'd be against it
all right sticking with this theme mr.
Trump I'm gonna ask you a little bit
about the Federal Reserve you think back
at all the Fed shares of the past who
you think's been the best well you know
right now you have janitors is you know
sort of more of the same and I have to
tell you I often talk with two hats I
for the last couple of months I've been
a politician I've been in your world and
previous to that I've been a business
person I've always loved
low interest rates as a developer and
I've always done very well with low
interest rates and I think that frankly
you know you look at what's going on now
the problem is I think you're creating a
and the bubble could explode I like Paul
Volcker a lot I thought he was a you
know terrific guy in so many different
ways and he had he had a good pulse that
he had a good good you know to me he had
he was doing what had to be done right
now we have the low rates again from the
standpoint of what I do in terms of real
estate if I want to develop I'm building
the old post office now I'm just
finishing up the Trump national Doral in
Miami from that standpoint I like to low
interest rates from the country
standpoint I'm just not sure it's a very
good thing because I really do believe
we're creating a bubble you said you
like Paul Volcker do you like the rule
named after him as part of dodd-frank
the Volcker Rule well I'm not sure if he
likes it but if he's you know what
honestly mark if he's happy I'm happy he
was a terrific guy I've met him a few
times and I thought it was terrific but
I think his his policy and his demeanor
there was something very solid about him
his demeanor were very good let me ask
you the same question John asked about
Fed chairs of EDS Treasury secretaries
if you look across the history of the
u.s. what's it who's the Treasury
secretary who you think was the best
well I don't think I have an opinion on
that I think we've had some good ones
we've had some bad ones but I really
wouldn't have an opinion on that we're
gonna I know they're talking about right
now lots of beautiful pictures on
beautiful bills and we're gonna see
whether or not that works out but I have
no real opinion on that I think actually
Federal Reserve right now in this world
the way we you know we've built it up
and probably has more of an impact than
almost any other position other than a
couple of Biggie's okay you don't want
to weigh in on any Treasury secretary
when you like let me just ask you about
a recent one who some people like some
people done what do you think of Bob
Rubin was he a good Treasury secretary
well I thought he was a smart guy and he
went I think with Citibank and then
Citibank crash right after he went so
that's sort of his reputation as far as
I'm concerned but I think he was a smart
guy I think he worked hard at it I you
know we were doing fairly well under him
he left and the world cratered so I
don't know does he get some point
deductions for that would have to take a
look at it certainly a Citibank didn't
do very well mr. Trump you said that you
tweeted the other day uh something that
suggested at least that some of your
Republican rivals might be puppets
for having gone to the Koch brothers
retreat out in California I want to ask
you a policy question the kind of
undergirds all that which is about
citizens united do you think that that
Supreme Court case was rightly or
wrongly decided well you know they're
very good friends of mine and David
posses a terrific guy and I know he
fights very hard I guess from my
standpoint personally I almost rather
not see it you understand that because I
see all of the money that's being raised
by these folks and they're raising you
know hundreds of millions of dollars and
ultimately billions of dollars and from
my personal standpoint because I'm I
don't need anybody's money and I want to
do it the old-fashioned way and I don't
like the fact that you know lots of
people are getting into the act so
personally I wouldn't like it overall
I'm not sure it's the worst thing in the
world I would like to see it a little
bit differently where it's not PACs
because these PACs are it's a total
phony deal when Bush raises a hundred
and some 1 million dollars and then he
waits and waits and waits because you're
not allowed to talk to the PAC and
you're not allowed to tell them and then
the money is sitting in there and then
he puts his best friend in charge or
somebody that's very closer and then
they never talk well if anybody believes
that they never talk it's a joke right
so well campaign finance reform you have
an important part of your platform and
if so what's the cornerstone of your
idea about campaign finance reform well
I think it could be it wouldn't be
number one I mean number one would be
trade number one would be Obamacare
repealing and replacing strengthening up
the military taking care of our vets we
have a lot of things you know things we
could talk all day long about things we
have to do but a campaign you know
finance reform it certainly would be
something that we could talk about and I
think more than anything else is
transparency
I mean there should be total
transparency so that if somebody's going
to do something and I think one of the
reasons I'm so high in the polls is
because everyone knows that all of the
lobbyists many of which I employ and you
still employ and I know many of them but
they have tremendous power over in fact
I end with the cokes I called it puppets
they have tremendous power over these
candidates and I'm not just talking
about coke I'm talking about lobbyists
I'm talking about special interests I'm
talking about donors and I was one of
the big donors I mean I know the system
better than probably almost
anybody almost as well as you guys would
know the system but you have tremendous
power when you give money especially
when you give substantial money over the
candidates and a lot of times those
candidates will do things fellas that
are very bad for the country but they
good for the company that the Power
Group represents mr. Trump we're gonna
spend the last couple minutes so if
you're talking about stuff that's not
really about politics just a couple
questions so that we can help our
viewers get to know you as a person a
little better one of my fundamental
fortune the road of life is the question
of whether you're a beatles person or a
stones person you a beatles person or a
stones person i really like a boat but i
guess i'll go with the beatles why is it
i know you like to golf i know you like
to spend time with your family what else
do you like to do these days for fun
well i guess a lot of fun is talking to
you guys just got back from scotland
because they own Turnberry one of the
great resorts of the world that we had
the Women's British Open there which is
their biggest tournament that I had to
be there for two days so I didn't even
get to say for the final day because I
was actually anxious to get back on the
silicon trail are you saying that down
between your work your business
campaigning family and golf you don't
have time for anything else fun I would
say pretty much I'm maxed out Wow Wow
there's no question about it my life is
an interesting life but I would say I'm
maxed out that does raise a question
though you know yeah you're you're very
busy we know that you tweet basically at
all hours of the day and night how many
hours a night you think you're getting
in the sack at this point I mean I was
just sleeping every night well
historically Jona haven't need it too
much and I think that's a genetic thing
I suspect or maybe it's a thing where
you love what you do you know it's also
that because when you know I know a lot
of people they can sleep all day because
they're not happy and they don't like
weather and I love what I'm doing
whether it's my business or now what I'm
doing now because I think we want to
really make America great again and and
I love what I'm doing and I guess I'm
emboldened by the polls that are coming
out because this so strong based on the
tweets it seems like you sleep four
hours a night is that right to say that
I'd say four
do you ever nap no I don't nap I don't
know you know I don't benefit compared
to some of the people you're running
against you're up twenty hours a day
that's pretty good
well I always say the people I mean I
have some friends that don't sleep very
much and I would say assuming you don't
need it I always say to him that we have
a big advantage because we have more
hours in the day to work and compete so
it is a definite advantage